and now it is time for the final thought  the left-wing violence erupting on  college campuses has nothing to do with  what conservative speakers have to say  it has everything to do with who  controls what they and therefore you are  allowed to say there is no alt left  there's just the left which has followed  it's bankrupt ideas to their logical  conclusions and now bereft of the  civilized argument that defines human  society and the reason that defines  humanity itself is left only to grunt  and scream like the animals that their  destructive ideas have made them become  Chesterton wrote there is a thought that  stops thought and that is the only  thought that ought to be stopped let's  wish Ben good luck in his speech and  hope that the thought that stops thought  doesn't stop him first  I'm Michael Knowles is the mic on all  show come back tomorrow get your mailbag  questions in we'll do it all again  [Music]  [Music]